[Music]
how did life begin I'm kind of
fascinated with beginnings how did life
begin as a question that I think we'd
all like to know out of the universe
begin so it's right up there with a
question that's tantalizing it's a piece
of knowledge that's part of the fabric
of our understanding of the world and
it's something that is I think
fascinating to people I always you know
like to know how things start there's
any number of things
whose beginnings you know they're big
things today what are they used to be
how did it how did it get where it got I
like building things I like to know more
how did things start now the universe is
one of those things I think the the
impact of the assignments observatory is
that it will reveal to us what really
happened to the universe 13.8 billion
years ago did it have a beginning
springing from some wild quantum
turbulent state or what really happened
as it underwent a bounce it was
originally contracting and then simply
began to expand due to some phenomena
that occur when it became very dense why
is all that important well because not
only tells us about where the universe
came from but where it's going it also
tells us about the nature of the forces
that control the universe that control
all the properties of the universe that
we observe today it makes a big
difference if you have a bang or a
bounce
for the Suns Observatory on the top of
mountain we're going to install several
telescopes of two different kinds what
is the so called large telescope it's
got a six meter diameter mirror and it's
going to be about four stories tall
it'll have a little elevator in it it's
a pretty big object but the really
special part of the telescope is in the
back it's the camera can't the
technology match the question I mean
that's exactly what we do in our
research we've known for a long time the
signal levels that we're looking for
they're very small order ten nanokelvin
and so we know what kind instrument we
would have to build to be able to even
approach that kind of single size
[Music]
twenty years ago that would have been
just unimaginable but we've been working
very hard to figure out how to make the
detectors more and more sensitive and
these lithographic techniques what we're
building now wafers like you would build
a computer processor and just like with
computer processors we're putting more
and more features into these silicon
wafers where we can put even some of the
optical elements that was previously
little lenses or or macroscopic parts
that you would machine they're now all
integrated on this planar silicon wafer
and that's really creating an explosion
in sensitivity for our field
we've gotten to the point where we can
ask the question can we see a signal
from inflation in the cosmic background
how does your instrument respond to a
signal on the sky ultimately what we
have to do is say oK we've got the
signal on the sky it goes through the
galaxy
it goes through the Earth's atmosphere
it goes through the receivers down so if
the optics comes in two detectors and we
get a signal a digital signal that we
record and we then have to convert that
digital signal back into a map of what's
on the sky a whole nother piece of the
science we do is first there's the
hardware of building the optics building
the receiver getting that electronic
signal
and then we've got to build the software
so we can use our computers to take that
electronic signal convert it back to an
image of what we actually think the sky
looks like it's a challenging game
because at any given moment 99.9% of
what you're picking up is not what's on
the distant sky but what's in the
Earth's atmosphere
now the Earth's atmosphere is varying
with time so if you keep recording the
signal the effects of the Earth's
atmosphere averages out and what left
behind is the cosmological signal one of
the challenges of our experiment is
actually surprising or we're gonna have
80,000 detectors out there on the mount
taking data all simultaneously and
that's going to create terabytes of data
that we have to move off the mountain
for what we're thinking of doing is
actually taking the data and bring an
optic fiber all the way to the
telescopes and so we have to dig a
trench you know for kilometers and we're
gonna bring it over from the nearby Alma
facility which is the big interferometer
which is about six kilometres away once
the data comes we bring it to centers
within the US and other places for
analysis then the data though goes to a
faster system where it sits on hard
disks and there we can access it really
quickly
most people think inflation is as valid
I'm on the fence actually either way we
win
personally I like the other theories
better it's hard for me to believe that
time began everyone imagines the time
would go on forever but why wouldn't it
have been going on forever why should
their why should time have started it
doesn't seem reasonable to me it's not
very aesthetic whereas something that
oscillated between big and small and big
and small and was always there there was
always a universe that aesthetically is
much more appealing to me
[Music]
what else can I tell you
some people say that Galileo was not
only the first astronomer to use a
telescope in history which is certainly
it seems to be the case but that he was
actually the first scientist of any kind
to use the scientific method where one
has a hypothesis perhaps test that
hypothesis uses data refines things
about it and throws away the parts that
don't comport with the observations that
he made it tickles me that we are using
basically the same kinds of technology
that Galileo used in 409 years ago which
is to say we're using on the Simons
Observatory telescopes that are made
with refracting lenses that are not
unlike the lens in your eye and that
when connected to the brain of a Titan
like Galileo or like my colleagues that
work on this project with me that they
we are able to see the invisible well
I'm very excited about it we were
supposed to see first light in three
years I think I can't wait I'm really
excited and I am certain that very good
science is going to come out of it one
way or the other I'm not certain what's
going to come out of it
but I'm sure it's going to be good
science
[Music]
[Music]
you